[Musik]
also aus meiner sicht hat insbesondere
die große koalition guten grund sich
jetzt mit dem klimaschutz verstärkt zu
befassen es gibt eigentlich drei gründe
warum sie das tun sollten
[Musik]
der eine grund ist dass ihr andere
themen praktisch ausgegangen sind bei
denen vorräte an gemeinsamkeiten da
wären im klimaschutz haben union und spd
einen großen vorrat an gemeinsamkeiten
weil sie sich zumindest auf das ziel
einigen können man hat sich ja
schließlich im rahmen des pariser
klimaschutzabkommens und auch in der eu
verpflichtet co2 einzusparen und diese
ziele sind auch festgelegt ist sehr sehr
deutlich geworden dass wir in den
nächsten wochen noch viel arbeit vor uns
haben es bleibt bei dem zeitplan
wir wollen am 20 september das komplette
maßnahmenpaket daneben auch im klima
kabinett verabschieden aber bis dahin
ist noch eine menge zu tun
der zweite grund warum die große
koalition jetzt was machen muss ist weil
die grünen steigen und steigen in den
umfragen sie haben gute wahlergebnis und
den grünen möchte man nicht das feld
überlassen union und spd haben beide ein
interesse daran die grünen aus zu
bremsen indem sie ein ambitioniertes
klimaschutz gesetz vorlegen und das
möglichst breit
der dritte grund ist der dass man damit
junge leute interessieren kann die frau
des future bewegung die jetzt jeden
freitag selbst in den ferien offenbar
noch weiterhin demonstriert für
ambitioniert mit zügigen klimaschutz das
sind junge zielgruppen die die parteien
spd und union normalerweise nicht so
bekommen und beide haben ein interesse
die zu wlan zu machen oder vielleicht
sogar auch zu unterstützern zu neuen
mitglieder insofern gibt es also drei
gründe sich jetzt schnell mit dem
klimaschutz zu befassen
[Musik]